MALE SPEAKER: Hi, and welcome.
We're here at Devoxx with
Ludovic Champenois.
Welcome, Ludo.
We're here to talk about Cloud
from Google and specifically
Google App Engine and Google
Compute Engine, which is the
latest one.
So, welcome, Ludo.
You had a presentation
here at Devoxx.
You mentioned App Engine, and
it's been around for a while.
It's been kind of
the pioneer in
platform-as-a-service clouds.
What have you been up to?
And by the way, you're the lead,
the Java lead for the
App Engine.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Yeah, I'm
taking care of the Java
runtime for App Engine.
App Engine is a very
long story.
It started in 2008, and only
last year, it came out of
preview so people could really
use the service in a
professional manner.
So it was out of preview last
year, November, and since
then, we have done almost 12
raises, so one per month.
So you can imagine, every month,
every single month, we
keep adding services to it and
tuning the load balancer or
tuning the scalability
of the service.
MALE SPEAKER: So you have
new features regularly.
So can you mention a few of
those new features that have
rolled out?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Yeah.
I mean, over the last year, we
added, I think, Python 2.7, Go
as a supported language.
We rearchitectured the data
store from master slave to a
high-replication data store.
MALE SPEAKER: So you added
something very interesting
called data splitting or
traffic splitting?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: We have
traffic splitting, where you
can split the traffic based
on IPs or cookies between
different versions of the
same application.
So, for example, you can try
some of your traffic to a
newer version of your
application.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
So one of the new things I hear
is European data centers.
So can you tell us
what that is?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: So I think
it was announced at Google I/O
in July, and it's starting
ramping up.
So, for example, before it
was only open to premier
customers, and I think
now we can open it to
all the build customers.
So it's basically App Engine,
but running in Europe in, of
course, multiple data centers,
but with a guarantee that your
data and processing power
will stay in Europe.
So customers are billed in euro,
and it's much easier to
be a customer when you
are from Europe.
MALE SPEAKER: So as the
Java lead, I need to
ask you this question--
Java 7 on App Engine?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS:
Interesting, yes.
So we are yes, of course,
working on Java 7.
In fact, the version of this
month is in preview mode for a
trusted tester.
And we will open it to
everyone in December.
So you can start testing your
application with Java 7.
Even if you do not use Java 7,
the new features, not all of
them are exposed yet in App
Engine because we are still
running the security around
the Java 7 runtime.
And you have seen recently some
hacks trying to enter--
break the security of the JDK
7 itself that have been
promptly fixed by Oracle.
But security is a very important
feature at Google,
and we want to make sure that
your application will run
securely in Java 7.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
So looking forward to that
before the end of
the year, Java 7.
So in terms of developer
experience nowadays, people
expect integration with Maven,
with continuous integration,
and they have all
those workflows.
How well do we--
does that work?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: For Maven,
the news of this month is we
are working on the--
so first of all, we publish all
the Maven artifacts for
all the JARs and libraries
and SDK for App Engine.
And what we are adding this
month is a new plug-in where
you can interact with App Engine
itself, so start the
local SDK, update your
application, update your
backends, et cetera,
et cetera.
So all of this from
Maven POM rules.
But we are also working
with two partners.
One of them is eXo to
do development on
the Web in the cloud.
And I don't know if you have
seen a demo of eXo IDE, but
you can open a Maven project
that you host on GitHub in the
web and start editing and
deploying it either to a local
SDK running in the cloud or the
real App Engine runtime.
So you don't need a
laptop anymore.
You need a Chromebook.
I mean, with a Chromebook, you
can effectively develop your
App Engine app if you want.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I've
actually Cloud IDE, and it's
very impressive.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: So this
is really for developers.
Now for testing and building
in a continuous manner, we
have also done a partnership
with Cloudbiz and their Dev
platform where you can run a
Jenkins build building your
App Engine app.
And As a post step for this
bid, you can deploy to App
Engine as well.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
That's great.
That, I think, helps developers
with their tasks,
daily tasks.
They're all used to
using Jenkins now.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Yeah, I
mean, outside of internal
Google, the defects are
still not outside yet.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So let's switch gears
a little bit.
You talked about App Engine,
but you also talked about
Compute Engine.
So tell us--
this is infrastructure as a
service running on Google's
infrastructure.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Yeah.
So App Engine is a big part
of the cloud offering from
Google, but we recently
introduced Compute Engine,
which is more getting from the
bottom, creating VMs and
networks, connecting those VMs
in a massive scalable manner.
The demo at Google I/O was using
600,000 cores to run
some computation on
Google Cloud.
So it's basically a Linux kernel
that you can create and
boot on demand and install
whatever software you want.
MALE SPEAKER: And so there's a
notion of API that you use to
manage all of this, because it's
at a scale if you have
hundreds of thousands or
even hundreds of--
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Yeah.
So the way you manipulate this
Compute Engine framework is
via a REST course,
so RESTful web
services with a JSON payload.
And we have a command line tool
and a nice web UI that
allows you to create your
payload seeds so you can learn
how to interact with Compute
Engine very easily.
MALE SPEAKER: So if I post the
proper JSON workload, I can
actually create an instance
and have it running?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: One
or 10,000 of them--
MALE SPEAKER: Of course.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: --depending
on your credit
card account.
MALE SPEAKER: And why
would I do this?
Do I get any benefit of running
my virtual machines in
Google's data center?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: So once you
have a VM running inside
the Google data center, then
this VM has the most powerful
network access to other
Google services--
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: --whether
it's cloud
storage or mySQL or Datastore.
So all the services will run
in the same data center, so
the communication
will be optimal
between those services.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So lots of progress on App
Engine and Compute Engine
coming soon?
This is still in preview
or in trusted testers?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Compute
Engine is still in preview
and, yeah, selected
trusted tester.
We are looking for massive
computation partners before
opening it more to
more developers.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
Well, I guess that's all the
time we have for it.
Thank you, Ludo, for--
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Thank
you for having me.
MALE SPEAKER: --spending
the time and
answering those questions.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Bye.